Today, kids in foster care – even those who suffer
from behavioral and mental health challenges– are not
very likely to be placed in a group care
setting. Of the 425,000 children in foster care,
only 55,000 are in group homes, treatment
facilities, and other congregate care settings – a big
drop since the early2000s.
What's behind this decline?
In the middle of the 20th century, philanthropists
responded to reports of orphanages as uncaring,
greedy operations, with a focused effort to keep
more kids at home or with foster families. Federal
and state governments joined in this effort, but
today, it's clear this movement has gone too far.
Despite the good intentions of philanthropists,
struggling foster kids now have few places to go.
Last summer alone, more than 400 children were
sleeping in offices in Texas. Philanthropists
should focus on building more quality congregate
care facilities like Utah Youth Village's Teaching-Family
Model – an evidence-based program where
married couples help kids develop the skills
they need to live in a real home. Programs like
this are the standard for the future of group care.
Do you think that there should be more quality
congregate care facilities for foster kids?
Let us know in our poll. Also, let us know
what other topics you'd like our scholars
to cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.